el sistema penitenciario de Ecuador es
nuevamente epicentro de violencia un
enfrentamiento se desató entre presos
armados con pistolas y cuchillos dentro
de la prisión de latacunga ubicada a
unos 80 kilómetros de quito la capital
del país el motín inició en la madrugada
del lunes 3 de septiembre y se mantuvo
durante varias horas del martes mientras
las autoridades lograron controlar la
situación dejando un saldo lamentable
como resultado de estos hechos se
registra al momento 43 personas heridas
y 16 fallecidas de las cuales 14
personas han sido identificadas luego de
las pericias efectuadas por el personal
de criminalística y Policía Nacional
según las autoridades los
enfrentamientos iniciaron cuando los
presos participaban del censo
penitenciario ecuatoriano el gobierno
central atribuye los hechos
principalmente a las luchas entre bandas
por el control de las rutas del
narcotráfico y confirmaron que Leandro
norero considerado uno de los
principales narcotraficantes del país se
encuentra entre los fallecidos los
familiares de los reclusos exigen
respuestas
no no se puede dormir en paz no cae ni
hambre ni sé sabiendo que lo que está
pasando aquí es una desesperación grande
para toda la familia
tormentas adentro
nos ven todo ahí porque les armamentos
están dentro a pesar de que el gobierno
anunció mejoras en la seguridad de las
cárceles este incidente es apenas el más
reciente en medio de la oleada de
violencia en los centros penitenciarios
del país solo en 2021 al menos 300
presos murieron en medio de motines
carcelarios en Ecuador